hi happy new year friend hi jennifer hi
i feel like i should actually call you
jennifer the dancing machine holland
because everybody i talked to today said
is that right john
yes absolutely
that you had the move sis that you were
the one
oh well thank you it was it was a lot it
was so much fun to do that dance
sequence karissa barton who did the
choreography uh did an incredible job
and she spent a lot of time with us
teaching us those crazy moves
okay who was best and who was worst i'm
gonna give because everyone said you
were best so i'm gonna let you make the
determination oh
man
i don't know i think
uh everyone was so good in their own way
really i mean like
you when you think of robert patrick do
you think oh someday i'm gonna do this
crazy dance with robert patrick you know
just getting to
to do that
crazy thing with all of these people who
were so
just
dedicated to making it exactly what it
was supposed to be everyone was fully on
board and really just jumped in and did
this thing
i love it that you know that we have a
little saying in the south jennifer that
says bless your heart if you really if
somebody really you know you just want
to make them feel good so that everyone
was good in their own way that's another
version of bless your heart
john cena it's sure good to see your
face i have not seen your face in such a
long time a long time and i know it's
virtual uh hopefully we'll see very soon
please please please but tell me this
what was it about this character what
was it about peacemaker that convinced
you to say okay i can take this from a
movie and i want to continue playing
this guy in a series oh man that's
that's not my choice i don't make those
choices that's that's from the mind of
james gunn uh james
thankfully went through a spell of
boredom which was uh definitely worked
to my advantage and wrote eight episodes
of peacemaker in eight weeks and he
called me up in the middle of
uh
probably the the most severe lockdown we
were going through and said hey i'd like
to get the band back together and do a
peacemaker series so i thought
peacemaker was dead i said well i got
that covered and i said okay let's do it
and that was our conversation about
moving forward with peacemaker well okay
you say it wasn't your idea but you
could have said no so there was
something about peacemaker that made you
say i want to keep going with this guy
oh well i mean um we did so much on the
suicide squad that never saw the light
of day uh and james and i had
conversations both about the character
and life in general and
we we've been through a lot of similar
experiences both coming from big
families uh we i don't know we just um
we talked about topics of philosophy uh
from from equal perspectives and
i think that led to
him seeing some of the outtakes and
possibly being like man there could be
a lot we could do with peacemaker and he
then was alone with his thoughts created
an ensemble and
there was no way
i was going to say no to working with
james again he is he is the name that
gets a free pass he could call me up and
be like hey i got this crazy idea do you
want in and i don't even need to know
what the idea is about and it's not only
because um personally he's a great human
being but professionally he is so
dedicated to what he does
when james writes a script
not only does he pick the score he will
write in the script where in the score
the song is playing he's extremely
descriptive and meticulous and it's that
attention to detail that i know that i'm
going to get a good story on the page
which is going to make me a better
professional why are you in your costume
costume this is a uniform and it's brand
new so i'm going to stretch it out make
it more comfortable before going to
mission jennifer you are a reluctant
warrior here with with peacemaker you
don't you really don't want any parts of
of him but there is this really fun
chemistry that develops with you too and
i wonder
where is it going can we you know
could there be some romantic feelings
uh
what a wonderful
question
i i think that
it's wonderful that you're asking that
and
i think everyone's just gonna have to
wait and see what happens and how it
develops throughout the series uh you
know where harcourt starts off in the
series is that she she i think she feels
much like a lot of uh probably
fans of the suicide squad feel
which is that she's she she just kind of
despises peacemaker
you know yeah me too oh my goodness i'm
sorry john this is the first time i have
never liked one of your characters and i
was so mad at myself watching this
because i was like why am i rooting for
this guy he's just a jerk oh he makes me
so mad but i want him to win that's kind
of what we're going for so thank you
very much
yeah it's crazy because i was i was this
i was a skeptic i was like you're making
a
you're making a series about what
character
um
and you know i was like well you know
james has a plan so i i trust him and
uh it's not just james's writing and all
of the things that he he develops for
who who peacemaker is but it's also just
a testament to john i mean the
likability factor you just can't deny
and so you're like oh god why do i like
you damn it
i tell me this john because we did spend
a good uh deal of time in our briefs uh
during this series and uh how tough was
it doing the fight scenes and nothing
but your skivvies
uh so without uh patent leather
wrestling boots or a set of reebok pumps
to grip on the floor it was pretty tough
but that's pretty close to my standard
uniform for two decades in wwe i'm
certainly uh certainly no i'm
very familiar with
uh
wearing less than a standard uniform and
um
i i you know i'm i'm comfortable with
who i am as a person and uh
i i really think the scene was or that
that scene is very powerful because it
humanizes peacemaker so that's one of
the reasons why it gets a person like
you to be like why am i rooting for this
guy well you find out he's yes he's and
yes he's heavily flawed
but when nobody's looking he's
vulnerable and when nobody's looking
he's innocent and when nobody's looking
he's naked and
he's okay like he doesn't he's not he's
not putting up
peacemaker he's being christopher smith
and um i really was hats off to james
for having a fight scene
in peacemaker in his tighty whities
because that just that in itself
is so abstract and so
against a superhero culture it really i
i love everything about that i can't
wait for the world to see it to talk
about it more but i love the fact that
he went all in on that well and i really
like the love story developing between
leota and chris in the friendship love
story and i'm with her when i say i want
to see more chris smith
because i think there's something about
chris smith that we love let me just say
this to you real quick john chikuti says
that he wants to challenge you to a
piano off i'm just putting it out there
he said you might choose something like
bohemian rhapsody he wants something
like chopin are you in
uh if if he's throwing out chopin i
believe i am out of my league but uh we
can learn a lot from a challenge and
especially learn a lot from a defeat i'd
love to do that i think that'd be great